good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight all week we have watched
our leaders hyperventilate about the
threat other countries pose to our
democracy for a national seek to
influence our election they have told us
again and again ominously and by the way
they're right some countries do do that
it's a fair point
but with that in mind it was a little
bit surreal to watch today as democratic
politicians in California encouraged
foreign nationals to actually vote in
our elections
it wasn't treason they explained how
could it be progressives are doing it
it's a form of civil rights in San
Francisco citizens of other countries
including illegal aliens are now allowed
to vote for school board other offices
will not be far behind you can be sure
of that San Francisco was the biggest
city to try this but the trend is
spreading nationwide in a number of
cities in the state of Maryland for
example foreign citizens can vote in all
local elections there's a push underway
in New York City and in Boston to allow
the same thing again none of this is
treasonous it's not a hacking of our
democracy
there's nothing Putin or Donald Trump
would do it is new york city councilman
Jumaane Williams recently explained to
us quote actually a restoration of
Rights non-citizens have been voting in
this country longer than they haven't
end quote
now we're not gonna pretend to
understand exactly what that means
we have no idea what it means we do know
that the left no longer even pretends to
believe in borders or in citizenship
they've rejected the notion that America
is even a country it's an idea
they tell us again and again though
really you get the sense they think it's
more like a division of Amazon staffed
by faceless replaceable drones meaning
you for now and then your foreign
replacement if you don't work eagerly
enough or if you complain
keep in mind none of this is a threat to
our democracy it's the essence of
democracy somehow in Samuel is a lecture
at Harvard Law School maybe he can
explain he joins us now yeah thanks for
coming on so hey thanks glad to be back
the reason that people are upset that
Russia hacked our democracy attempted to
interfere in our elections and I think
they have a right to be upset about that
is that Russians aren't Americans
they're not citizens
only citizens have the right to
influence a democracy that's what
citizenship is it's the right to do that
to self-govern so with that in mind why
the same people who are upset about
Russia doing this encouraging other
foreign nationals to vote well I think
the reason is is that it's not that
people are upset that Russia is
interfering with American elections
because those people aren't citizens
it's because they're hostile to the
United States and long-term residents of
the United States aren't in the same
position and as you know you quoted sort
of at the top voting by non-citizens is
quite common actually it had persisted
in the United States until the early
part of the 20th century before the
party it's the same thing okay it's not
it's not the same thing so so in other
words it's a matter of intent so anyone
who meets your definition of being not
hostile to the United States as defined
I assume by you or other Harvard law
professors gets to vote so in other
words if Putin were to say I'm not
hostile to the United States I actually
like Donald Trump I think he said that
on stage on Monday then that would give
him the right to influence our elections
by your standard well the the
traditional test up until I think
Arkansas was the last state to eliminate
non citizen voting in 1926 the
traditional test was residency permanent
residency and so you know when Abe
Lincoln was elected on the backs of lots
of non citizen voters in Illinois which
was true in the 1860 election I don't
think there was something illegitimate
about what we can't be hold on we
actually can't be sure what was true
from the 1860 election because we didn't
have the capacity to survey it in the
way we do now so what's your engaging we
know what the law is do you know that
you only know I allowed non-citizens to
vote we don't know what we're just a
bunch of them voted for Lincoln okay we
don't know that and I don't work in her
back so we're not gonna pretend any of
it but but let's let's not let's move to
the present from the past year let's
step ahead you know 100 and if we could
and ask an original it's not like the
past what can I say right so but why
would it be wrong for Putin if his
intent was pure to influence our
election by the standard that you just
laid out and this is sincere question
because I don't understand how you could
be mad about Russian meddling and then
you're encouraging non-citizens to
choose officeholders well I think if
Vladimir Putin wanted to leave Russia
and become a permanent resident of the
United States I would encourage him to
vote there's no such thing as permanent
residency for an illegal alien he has no
residency in illegal aliens not that's
just historically that's not right no
that's not right historically I'm not
quite sure what you mean by that I'm
talking about 2018 let's say mid July
2018 how about today and illegal aliens
are now allowed to vote in San Francisco
there's no permanent residency by
definition they're not residents they're
here legally and they're allowed to vote
why is that okay
but Putin influencing election not okay
why is that not treason and hacking our
democracy well I just
III don't know how else I don't know how
better to put this like look I I as I
said I am an originalist I believe that
the central government should not be
involved in telling States who can and
cannot vote the Constitution doesn't
assign that responsibility would you be
okay with Calif would you be okay with
California saying anybody from Russia
any Russian intelligence agent who wants
to influence our election go ahead well
I think I would not I would not on the
merits right I would of course I
wouldn't on the merits because I would
draw the line differently I would draw
the line at residence people who live in
a place and it tends to remain very
common but let's just be chasm as a
matter of fact since this is an issue be
clear on what California is requiring
there's no measure or test for residency
they're not saying you have to intend to
stay in San Francisco before voting or
prove residency on the same score even
be here legally so what you're saying is
irrelevant to the actual facts of this
it's true that they may have decided as
a practical matter to draw the line a
little more over-inclusive but I would
note that everybody who lives in San
Francisco for whatever period is subject
to the laws there and so it's not
actually crazy to suggest that they
should have some input onto what those
location would be so again the
historically normal so so we just had a
Russian intelligence agent arrested
yesterday she's now in jail without bail
her crime as described by the federal
government is trying to influence
America with
registering under the foreign agent
Registration Act what did she do wrong
she was a long-term resident of this
country she was involved in a romantic
relationship with an American she spoke
English she had a vested interest in
this country and yet she's in jail
without bail would you defend her uh
well I think that there's a great deal
of difference between a person being an
actual spy versus a person who is where
they said no no it's held that sure no
one's alleging she's a spy she's not
accused of stealing anything I'm spying
on anybody she's accused know I read the
indictment and you should too
she's accused merely of trying to
influence this country without
registering so what did she do wrong and
why aren't you leaping to her defense oh
because she's not voting Democrat as far
as I know she might you know I have no
idea but there what she did wrong is she
violated an actual federal statute that
prohibits and perhaps that statute is
unwise but what is true is that the
Constitution assigns to each state the
decision to decide who is gonna vote is
that principle and you've changed the
principle like four times first you said
they have to like the United States and
then you said I doubt really then you
said they have to have lived here for a
long time now not really and now you're
saying what if you violate a law so you
I'm sure you're for enforcing all the
races but you're not I am come I am
comfortable with the idea that anybody
who is subject to the laws of the United
States and resides here in the ordinary
sense should have an input into the
political process and so that send all
that I hope you were a finesse for this
woman's legal defense because it sounds
like by your standards you got
railroaded so you know I mean I think
I'll do it for free free the Russians I
know you all right thank you what can
they see thanks a lot